this is a real thoughts on labyrinth my
real thoughts is that dance magic dance
is incredibly catchy and says I review
the movie again I've actually made a
copy of it to play my car oh my real
thought is it's fucking labyrinth
who doesn't like labyrinth oh I think
there is well when it came out I don't
know many people liked it fuck those
guys yeah um I do feel bad you know let
me tell you about when I first came
across this movie because I want a came
across as well it's like 12 or 13 and
you missed this one we like ompletely
missed it why really is that sudden my
multiple times in the eighties it I I
ran down was like David the church like
when they would this get play to the
church group once which i think is
really interesting but um that that's
how they teach about sexuality Joan of
David Bowie's package okay but no I
complete was not like this here because
I thought I kind of saw all these types
of movies while I was young I really
liked him and one day I think we were at
our grandparents house and everyone was
kind of out III think like I got there
early and you're with somewhere son so
like I was pretty much in this house
alone I was just watching TV and it was
like Showtime or something in movie
colaborate came on I had never heard or
seen or anything this movie so imagine
going in completely blind you seen this
girl I really weird like you know just
like it on it towards me she was kind of
Lucas fine like Lucas his name is
attached to this I feel like somehow he
infected her act but but like socially I
mean it's a young Jennifer count and and
then out of nowhere just suddenly one of
my favorite cuts of all time just cut to
these goblins sleeping oh listen I don't
like I think you look like Elvis command
Bender's David Bowie it's sparkling what
a crazy hair
Kimbo II from then on I'm just watching
this like what the hell am i watching
and I I really really love it I uh but
the fight though watching it I could
pick up very quickly I picked up okay
this is like I didn't know what to call
it back then but I knew it was that
category of like a tease we're creative
movies where it's like the story and the
character everything was not the focus
the focus was an excuse to have all
these cool visuals this little journey
these fun ideas and these little rhymes
and stuff like that okay these films did
a lot of now exposition it just dumped
you it's like an anime just happen
straight into it yeah well with no no
real rhyme or reason or explanation and
what little explanation comes come
slowly over the course of the movie and
I you couldn't make this film nowadays
you just couldn't that style of
filmmaking for maybe a lot more modern
comedy yeah a lot more CG yeah that
style of filmmaking to me is so dead
yeah um but even the idea of just like
and we're gonna have her be a complete
bitch to her baby brother and then poof
she's in the magic maze and this all
happens over the course of like seven
minutes like it you just couldn't do it
and oh and the first thing's gonna be a
little uh guy in a full suit pissing
into the moat like bit that's your
opening scene with that guy like it what
universe could you make this movie
nowadays yeah um and I remember you
killing fairies as am
ya know I would pick me ash when fairies
do I love a film that creates you know
sort of this fantasy world where it's
like oh you think these things you think
you know these fantasy things these
fantastic things you don't
fairies are actually little pains in the
ass that'll bite you and they need to be
aghast and stuff like that and it's like
I love that I love the white take the
Goblin King was not a hideous looking
goblin it's David David Bowie's with a
goblin in his pants um I I first saw two
I was like I was a little thrown off at
first by the 80s music cuz I was a
rotten little 12 13 year old out just
again it's the pit
damn but like in now especially I just
love me Smashing Pumpkins uh but now I
don't know I love bending to uh tell Rob
Zombie like all that stuff and knowing
that's good I feel like oh this is
timeless I would say that a jelly
there's at least Rob Zombie's pretty
awful I don't know um um but yeah it's
one of those things so and so I'm
watching this and you know it's just
getting stranger and stranger and like I
said I just immediately accept what kind
of movie this is supposed to be and I
just take it all in even though I knew
you know cuz this is when like Aladdin
was coming out and Lion King where all
the we were motel references were there
and I was kind of saying like you know
ok as a dumb 12 13 year old right now I
wish they're more of these references
but I knew like there was something for
lack of a better term kind of magical
about this film and it was the
environment was modern modern Disney and
filmmaking in the 90s became very
trending the word polished everything
was polished sort of glowing kind of
clean you know ladies was dirty the 80s
was dirty gritty not as dirty and gritty
as the 70s like the new wave was coming
in and 80s were getting sort of glammed
up a bit but still most of those he
eighties was in the 70s without the Sun
yeah it was it turns the the doramas and
the graininess and in the 90s there was
very little I could think of a few
examples The Crow um the last Disney
film of that type was probably in its
own strange way hocus pocus I always
felt like there was kind of a weird sort
of set feel to everything and it was a
little more but it yeah like everything
was just super polished and and clean
and where is like the 80s films you
always felt like you were in a different
universe like this was a scary dark
gritty kind of universe where everything
was kind of mucky and there were things
in the shadows and again you couldn't
really make this home that is even
something like what the closest maybe
the last Potter film but I think of even
something that Harry Potter or the Star
Wars prequels it
clean all the CGI again I mean one of
the great things about force awakens is
that you know it was dirty again
yeah I mean maybe Lycia sounds there I
really kind of felt like it were force
awakens have reminded me a little bit of
labyrinth cuz like so much as stuff was
really there all the nice thing but but
when I wasn't now I got we're CG when
they do have to put something in there
it looks more like it's there than with
the blue screen with those fire monsters
or whatever well then well that's a
maybe laughs we were looking at the back
of the DVD box and we're like this is so
dead it's like from the master of myth
himself George Lucas I'm like wow that
chain three prequels the one who sold
his mythology off because everybody
hated where his fucking myth lament but
gave it all to charity I still finger
through that oh I did trust me I'm not
gonna complain George Lucas selling off
Star Wars was the best thing yet um so
I'm not I'm not bitching about him for
that trust me I'm like thank you just
rich thank you um but yeah it just shows
you how David this was cuz this would
have been like mid 80s or whatever back
when it was like Star Wars was still
best shot and not just shit um and there
was something you know because obviously
we wanted to do this after David Bowie
died and a lot of people been asking for
it and we're kind of saying like well
Lindsey kinda did it's a really funny
review and I am one guy I might we do on
my public-facing we were like you can't
do that Lindsey did it it's wrong yeah
like is if there's some unwritten rule
like I'm like what no ice no there's no
rule book or law here yeah that's what
chains are also I thought really say
it's like you know is there a rule book
cuz nobody gave me that rule but no one
gave me votes no no well yeah no one
Somoza know that I can't do it then I'm
G at the memo duck yeah like if it's
been reviewed before by anybody you
can't do what I usually try to do if a
movie is done by somebody and I feel
like there's nothing new I can add I try
to stay away from it I really liked
Lindsay I mean the only thing we added
that was new were the numerous dick
jokes yeah but that's again there's just
so many then we can do what we'll talk
about how we keep open with those in a
second um but so I
like maybe my Styles get different
enough and you know maybe I've been away
from it along long enough I can sort of
think of it new jokes and stuff and when
David Bowie died it just suddenly like
that is kind of like one of the major
introductions to him is that a lot of
people were introduced to him through
lab or anything obviously his music as
well probably more but you know a lot
were introduced through labyrinth and
you see him pop up in that movie and I
think that actually kind of was my
introduction to David Bowie like maybe I
heard a song as if I didn't know if like
the creature David Bowie like the man so
when I see him in the smooch I want to
refer to him as the creature David Bowie
from now on yeah he's just this entity
and when you fer the Oh being entity
that came down from the cosmos to Greece
but when I first see him in the movie
its earliest sparkles and any so 80s and
so strange so 80s and yes so not also
and I'm like and again to this 12 13
year old that just loves to judge things
I'm looking it's like I don't know where
this guy falls he looks kind of weird
and goofy but is he just like kind of
dumb or whatever and as soon as he says
you really were a dick in high school
everybody at 12 or 13 is especially if
you're a boy you're a total asshole um
I'm just now I'm just remembering you in
Nice comes okay you were pretty
pretentious no that's no high school did
1213 I think it was still like you know
well that's like fifth or sixth area
something like that when I got into high
school that's where the real pretension
to start that is teeth I just don't know
where this Bowie characters coming from
yeah no that's high school uh when when
I saw this like I say I was in like
fifth or sixth grand just like you know
not knowing but as soon as he says what
said is I mean it's just immediate
presence he just grabs you with that
voice in the way he says the lies and he
makes these lines that are not
especially like phenomenal or even the
mammalian girl like it early puberty but
just he just took command of that role I
mean he just totally embodied it and
made it so cool it's like so Hades and
so corny may respect but it is so cool
no it's definitely it's one of those
movie
it was like with those sexual awakening
movies for a lot of kids because the
girls had David Bowie and the guy said
oh we had Gemma Kali Jennifer Connelly
one of my early crushes and it's like I
mean when you're a kid it's okay
cuz she's like a young teen and this is
like then when we saw The Rocketeer
Jennifer Connelly that that's why I
think she's like the most oh oh she's
beautiful in that movie
no and Ellen she isn't like and I was
attracted to Howard she looked but like
the personality and the voice and
everything was a huge turn away food
rots really I know I think she gets
better as you know I was on she drops
that English accent she's got that
George Lucas English accent um we're
climbing Lucas for so much but chances
are he really didn't have that much
she's doing baby you know what the funny
thing is I still want to blame him cuz
it feels like one of his fingerprints
you know guys my orange guy speaking of
Brits yeah Terry Jones Monty Python
helped write it um
he's written a lot of fancies and
they're a lot of fun um you know I kind
of feel bad because he kind of got like
some of his projects didn't do very well
or they guess what done it is somewhere
even that good I liked Eric the violin
is you are David
Zero's I never got that I'm like of all
the movies okay okay okay it's a two
star movie at worst alright and my god
yeah like I had Zoe this is an OE okay
film and the film is problems I'm like
yeah that one was so slammed I'm like
this is perfectly fine you want to say
it's a blah film that's a bit 0 stars
Jesus Christ like he also did uh he
wrote and directed I believe a wind and
the Willows that is not very good and it
is the veteran bizarre she has a one
song that's awesome made it oh you're
tapped Emily yeah but but but he really
can write so are these fun weird
fantasies but Jim never invented like
that's that's what I love like all of
that they're puppets they're all except
when it's not and man did he not do
those well okay well the blue-screen you
mean the blues green is that it without
a way that really was one of the
shittiest blue-screen effects I have
ever seen like I was just like oh my god
I can't even say like Allah was the 80s
know if you want your film and you were
born in the late 90s or something like
don't think that's what blue screen in
the 80s was like I'm like no that was
bad even by 80 stands well that's what's
so interesting about hence is that you
do realize how comfortable he was that
he had to do stuff that was there and
how uncomfortable and not familiar he
was with the blue screen stuff cuz I'm
sure you know if you see how they move
in everything I saw a little bit behind
the scenes you know what the people in
the blue suits and everything it is
kinda like oh well that isn't it you can
see them like oh this will be a neat
opportunity let me try this and then
when it's all put together like and
either have the hopeful goggles on or
something like that and it just didn't
work in man agent were too made HR
Pufnstuf look like Lord of the Rings I
just was so Qi and he didn't return to
it I mean he kept doing everything in
front of the camera like it had to
actually be there there very few times
where he did blue screen you know and I
mean you can see through some of the
facts when the balls are rolling and the
and you know yes Lisa where is our
puppet you're never you never think like
oh this is not like I know but I
actually hear this from people um who
are just like well I don't get it
because like it just doesn't look real
like why is the puppet more real than
CGI and I'm like because it's there
yes entirely there and even there is CGI
and I'm everyone tries to say oh you're
anti CGI I'm really not a just one I
just wanted I liked all the see things I
like all this CGI Mad Max noises there's
a lot of CGI like most of the CGI in
Lord of the Rings
I like there's some battle scenes now
and I'm like these did not hold up like
it though but tons of siege and Lord of
the Rings is still really the compare
the comparison I use is that I say I
love Who Framed Roger Rabbit and that
they use hand-drawn animation to bring
those creatures to life I don't want to
see it for everything I don't want to
see hand-drawn animation all over in
Star Wars I don't want to see it all get
labyrinth I don't want to see it all
over in the mask I want to see various
tight air sex I'm used to keep the
illusion seem there is something to
practical effects that you could reach
out and feel like
you can touch it because it really is
there the computer program is not there
you inserted it after the fact and there
is a difference and we're getting way
closer like I feel like before I die I
will see it where I can't tell the
difference but we're still not there yet
I'm still like okay that's not there
though then that's that variant I sort
has fool me but it's very it's very rare
and here's the thing you have to eat
with a movie it's already an illusion
you're looking at flat screen and yet
you're feel like you're being sucked
into a world and characters problems and
stuff with uh with a puppet you know
it's a puppet you know but it feels like
it's alive in the personality Yoda in
Empire Strikes Back really yoga always
the best no no now that Yoda feels more
real as the puppet than he ever did is
CG and the CGI really wasn't bad either
like in Revenge of the Sith it just
still couldn't compare but here's the
thing that vets so there's already a
filter you know it's a puppet you know
but you know says one filter yet to get
through but they need to believe it's
really alive and that's and that can
help you believe it's really there with
CGI it's two filters you know it's a
puppet and you know it's not really
there and that's two filters that makes
it tougher to make the connection now
saying it doesn't work there's lots of
times where it works uh but I think it
is so overused and we're relying on too
much that we're not using this variety
that should be you here's like what are
you doing in for is the puppet you know
something is really there the trick is
to make you forget it's a puppet with
CGI you know it's not really there so
it's trying to convince you it's really
there and I find that much harder to do
um there's a few times they've done it
like golems pretty close um you know
there are some characters and uses of
CGI supreme leader snoke come on own up
pretty amazing not so good um but it but
generally it's like it's way harder
because there is nothing there it's
easier to make you forget the performers
there in the puppet that is to make you
convince you that your computer
programmed creation is actually there in
the scene with the other person but like
with uh with those fire creature
or whatever how much better would that
been if they use CG to do the blue
screen and move them around and stuff
like that like they did later with like
Muppet Christmas Carol and stuff oh yeah
like that's a scene that's a scene oh my
god I'm wishing they had CGI no there
are times and there are times where the
movements not quite right or it is a
little distracting the way they will say
what about you babe agency would have
helped if they did that it would take
away from kind of the charm of all the
practical effects it's like it's bad but
no no you could just you know to me
maybe like a hit nicer you know CD with
it I mean it would be kind of just as
jarring just in the opposite way just
like wow that looks really clean and
polished versus everything else is all
grimy and I'm talking more about just
like the little movements how about this
I want you just cut the fucking scene to
begin with because there's no point to
it
well no I'm talking about effects in
general like the rolling rocks coming in
at the end like some of those a lot of
those are on tracks and some of the get
rolling five others are barely rolling
I'm like okay we'll see gl one of those
just to make them roll that would be not
guardians I actually got guardians of
the galaxy did a good job but it seems
you like Rocket Raccoon I'm really good
I believe this guy's but that there was
all this attention to detail - yeah that
I think the animators they either don't
get the budget for which I think is most
of it half thought or the time but yeah
but like okay like when what was the
same Drax the big guy who didn't read
yeah yeah when he what's it I think I
was in witty pets Roger yeah at the end
and rocket just like heads like this
animal reaction where he shot like such
a little detail and it completely sold
that puppeteers can do that in their
sleep because they're they're unset
doing it it's harder to just have an
animator like come up with that and be
like in the ones that do like credit -
guardians of the galaxy it's amazing and
give them a fucking raise or give them
the budget to do that to begin with but
it's a little harder than actually being
on set and being there there's is like a
disconnect mm-hmm yeah when you can work
off of the actors a little bit more -
like if you were to pet a puppy go like
that that's just very natural and where
the way it would move you know is very
natural and unpredictable as well where
everything has to be calculating a
computer and again that's not saying it
isn't done phenomenal sometimes are like
CG Adam
it films are amazing and stuff like that
it's just that it's replaced everything
that's kind of a shame even with puppets
you have to find all these various ways
to do stuff they can't all just be socks
you know you had to find different kinds
of animals and people in suits and
combine things in the stuff where it's
let you imagine if they tried making
this movie now I'd everyone's like
they're breaking the rebooting it I've
heard that debunked um Paris I know it's
not add apparently at most it was more
like we're talking about it but yeah
there's a lot of Henson projects though
that are like being talked about that
have never come to fruition so but the
thing is one I'm like trying think okay
if you made this movie now what would be
first I'll maybe three hours long that
even if it's a kid to me like the Potter
series gets longer and longer so B Nobi
two movies yeah it would be possibly two
movies it would be insanely long there
would be a good 35 minutes of exposition
where am I
what is this labyrinth characters
explaining it to her you would have more
time spent in the real world and all the
things that she wants and this and that
she would not be such a bitch to her
brother
that's right I'm sure you couldn't do
that now don't know the brother wouldn't
be a little baby it'd be like you know
yeah be a kid yo kid you know who has
like one more little brother well we'll
say one swear word to get you know the
little girls laughing um probably
wouldn't be a girl because you can have
like a girl in a movie because that
doesn't sell enough toys who reverse it
so you probably got a older boy anyway
you would still it would sit would still
be a girl
they just won't have time possibly
though I think they would just reverse
the genders like I I think it would be
like an older boy chasing after a whole
sister or something or annoying Brad
either yeah you'd be wandering around
everything would be CGI there would be
no puppets
unless Abrams directons that were
putting fucking puppets in this movie
and I would respect him for that um yeah
you wouldn't have the pissing you
wouldn't have the pissing guy you
wouldn't like half of the really
discussing things you and Abood would be
it would look very pretty it would be
very pretty probably brightest except
when it needs to be dark it would just
have this blue green filled
over everything well it would be aimed
at the tween crowd as well it would
probably be like Maze Runner with a
touch of Hunger Games at the oh you need
to you need to have a romance it can't
just be the Goblin King so then probably
need to be some other I'm just good like
Goblin King will be her age that's what
it yeah it would be her age is it that's
the thing I'm looking at how they made
this film and like it was such a time
capsule movie I'm just like this
violates so many these films violate all
the rules of quote/unquote modern
filmmaking post 1994 like I feel like
films I feel like maybe 94 95 poster
assic park post Independence Day that's
when everything started changing for me
it's like now we're in a new era of film
yeah the Lord of the Rings Potter
Twilight huh yeah yeah that was my
thought um that's when that Dark Age
started um and we're out of that Dark
Age but it is funny because I'm like
this is I felt very old watching this
movie I'm like wow this is what I grew
up with it is so different from the ship
kids grew up in it's just so like I
could just look at all I liked the set
so there's one scene where it's like the
giant monster goes inside this house
climbs up opens up the roof and you see
the landscapes done all in one shot and
I'm just marveling at all the will you
do that out is going to be this Sochi it
would be the CGI camera going through a
CGI house you'd be going up all these
levels here what you're really going
through the window yeah circling right
yeah because you would also be in 3d yes
um yeah there's something about that
simplicity like I said it's just taking
away that other filter of it not being
there we know it's an illusion we know
it's not real but you have to jump
through two filters to make the
connection and it's just so much easier
getting second anyway so you know it's
actually there it's the simplicity and
it's funny because it's so much more
complicated to do it practically it is
um which is not to say like I always
hate scene because I feel like oh no
workers into CJ oh it's a fuck ton of
work yeah II don't know stammers mean
but if you give them enough money and
enough time the CGI guys can figure it
out practical effects its conduce just
some shots where it's just like you have
to get really fucking inventive you
can't just program it take the extra ten
days and program it into the computer
that forces you to get more interest
angles and compromise and tell story in
a different way so on the one hand it's
more calm can but on the other hand
you're right there is a Zen simplicity
to these older films of just these grimy
little sets and it's something I miss
nowadays is a sense of mystery there's
no mystery everything's explained
everything's kind of bright and shiny
like I really feel these older films
that we grew up with had this sort of
dark sense of mystery they did not
fucking hold your hand that is the huge
difference I feel like modern films kind
of like take a kid's hand like come
follow me this will be fun in like the
80s wombs literally picked you up threw
you in this world and says survive this
motherfucker you know again with the
exception of as us the audience I mean I
sure as I refills to but the one that
jumps into my head like no not not that
one uh is actually force awakens I'm
thinking about how that really was kind
of dark it was kind of dirty and even
though was it all dialogue yeah and even
though it was a lot repeating you know
that bothers me I'm thinking of just how
invested I was and how it really felt
like I was in this world and there was
this mystery and there was this sense of
what's gonna happen even if it's on
repeat I'm so going like what's gonna
have and they're there are some films at
the like of films the stop-motion films
corrala Oh Aaron Norman I wasn't even a
huge fan of boxtrolls but that man
that'll reminds me of labyrinth in some
ways he's like and here's this fucked up
universe no explanation this guy just
really likes cheese yeah and then like I
did appreciate that that weird it's
almost like a British like this
something to British stories that are
very odd I don't want to say off-putting
but it's definitely weirder though I
have the whole world focus on one
strange thing and like the economy and
the set of everything is sort of round
these 1080 zooms II ended today same
thing yeah it was just like we're just
gonna give you this odd slice of a
universe and enjoy or don't we don't
care like we're here to give you an
experience
yeah those films like Coraline and those
zooms do that they break Coraline and
ParaNorman and and box those to me are
80s movies they yeah that feel your
Quinn's dark mysterious don't hold your
hand here
a little bit of a difference that I
think is an improvement of what we're
doing now is that there's a sense that
the films may now have to have a little
bit more of a purpose of a moral of a
focus on you know connecting with an
audience we're with labyrinth it's like
what's the moral I'm sure if you think
about you can pull out something but
like with Coraline and ParaNorman and
stuff not only are the good morals and
good lessons but the ones they've taught
in such a unique and interesting way
that you don't see that often I guess
maybe something like Coraline it's like
the morals simply the grass is always
greener on the other side of the fence
and but it's done it you can connect so
much more with how they do it there than
with whatever they don't seem like just
kind of very basic fairy tale kind of
but something that's what I like to talk
about the basic the connection with it
you know the with Coraline and and the
parents and the world with that
connection ParaNorman googan with the
witch and everything oh yeah no that's
you but but that's another it's like the
freakin kill a kid off in a movie like
that um or Coraline is another example
where the parents and and Coraline
they're all really bitchy to each other
yeah like I miss that this is maybe I
miss mean-spiritedness and films I don't
know but like there was something about
the 80s that it felt a little more for
his glam e'en as weird as it could get
it felt a little more real in the way
kids feels more honest yeah kids swore
in the 80s - you don't see that much
nowadays um I mean we're I'm not buying
mean saying like oh the 80s they had
everything no there's a ton of problems
with the 80s as well and things that
don't add up well and the phone that's
the thing labyrinth there are some
things we can take from a lab I hope we
are now with films like labyrinth and
films like it feel like certain animes
you see where they just dump you in
tell a quick story and then leave um you
know a lot of anime movies do that and
there's pros and cons of that it's kind
of fun you get a slice universe at the
same time you're right you it is hard
sometimes to get as invested because
it's like it's hard to connect early
especially yeah cuz they just dumped you
into it and yeah there's pros and cons
with like it for me it's refreshing
because we so see the opposite nowadays
where they see so inundated were talking
talking exposition talking you know and
explaining everything away that
it's refreshing to see that at the same
time I'm like yeah I'm like legitimately
looking at this with a critical item
like they really just throw you right
into this world with no rhyme or reason
just and even the exposition goblins
woke up here we go
even the exhibition next position they
do have in the opening with her and the
mother and stuff like acting even a
night in just including current just
everyone the mother and the father is de
it's pretty awkward The Muppets are the
best actors including the one in David
Bowie's pants yes oh we should bring
that up by the way I just told Rob I was
like look I think it's so many David
Bowie dick jokes and I just I wanted a
list I just go through a bunch of them
just get me however many okay you're
like what are you looking for I'm like
25 yeah 20 to 25 something like that
I'll pick the best one I I was talking
and I'm like well um like a couple
things one those have all been done to
death I'm not sure how much of richer
because he's like they need to be
original ones um I heard before I'm like
like I don't know if they're already I
haven't heard before because everybody
makes fun of that part of the movie I
knew it I knew I could come up with them
but I have to really just sit there and
think only on that I can write the rest
so yeah there's a couple problems I
don't know if I can come up with them
any their original cuz they've all been
done to death I had anything you and I
and I said and honestly I'm like dick
jokes aren't really my forte that's more
your forte that's a nostalgic that's a
nostalgia critic thing that's not really
like my style of comedy I'll make a dick
joke every once in a while but I'm look
I'm not an expert at it like you're in
like literally dug on the other side
phones like Rob I have faith like it
alright I'll give this a try so the next
day I like literally sat down at the
computer like open Notepad it was like
demolition man I was like what's his
uptight possessed accordion to like
typed out like 30-something something
dick jokes in five minutes
so after five minutes of just typing
straight I just stared at the computer
and I was like wow how sad is it that
this is my super-secret mutant
and even FG use Anthony we're coming up
with more oh I thought it I went oh
you're phenolic oh here's another hi all
this time my secret mutant power was
diksha I will utilize your dick jokes oh
wait oh where does somebody have posted
my public Facebook and somebody's like
it is a blessing it is also a curse
so yes him - thank you
I had no idea all these 36 years I've
spent on this planet and I had no
freaking clue that I could just call up
dick jokes without even thinking about
it although I came up with the fondling
the dark crystals her hands off my dark
crystals joke all the Artic Jim that was
that was that was good
um so yeah I think go out on dick joke
um I can't forget too much else to say
laboratory yeah they definitely enjoy it
nah can't like it's perfect or a minute
here someone any old who was born in the
90s even if you don't like the movie you
have to watch it cuz 80s awareness you
should be aware of this movie watch it
you don't have to like it it was a
different time um I can't see anyone
watching it saying there was nothing in
there I liked like or anything over you
a monastery you should at least be like
okay maybe I didn't think much there's
ideas too in there and riddles and jokes
and you know imagination there's all
these very things bitch pissing in the
rivers and killing fairies like they'll
only picture they'll be something like
there's something in there you'll like
you won't go out like I got nothing out
of that movie whatsoever and if you do
you suck yeah you suck so yeah that's
about it
uh thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed the movie if not you suck he
said it you suck